so the PAW Patrol they should totally be
dead in the newest movie part of a
meteor hits Adventure City destroying
the PAW Patrol Tower before crashing
down into the streets thankfully the
pups save the day by clearing everyone
into nearby buildings and in the final
couple of seconds hiding themselves
behind things like newspaper stands and
in the trunks of cars but no then ain't
doing anything in reality Adventure City
would have been leveled see meteors move
fast between 11 and 77 km a second about
25,000 mph and because they have so much
velocity they are carrying a lot of
energy no matter how big they are in
2013 for instance a 19 M meteor exploded
over Russia with 30 times as much energy
as the atomic bomb given the size of
what you're seeing here in the movie
sorry Paw Patrol you're not just playing
dead after that
[Music]
one hello Internet welcome to film
Theory the show that refuses to let
sleeping dogs lie so did you guys wait
in line to pre-order your tickets to the
latest PA Patrol movie like I did cuz
let me tell you in our family this was
the most hyped movie ever in my life old
my Pup Pack Avengers endgame the PAW
Patrol Mighty movie is where it's at now
you might be thinking I'm over
exaggerating but no this is actually a
true story this was my son Ali's first
official movie in a theater based on the
fact that he shouted this movie is so
awesome unprompted four times throughout
the film I'd say that it exceeded his
expectations anyway in case you don't
know Paw Patrol is a series about a
group of rescue service puppies led by a
boy Genius named Ryder now in our
previous theories we uncovered the Dark
Truth hidden under this polished
merchandise friendly exterior exposing
the fact that Ryder is actually a
Cutthroat capital using stray pups as
cheap Expendable labor to do dangerous
rescue missions paying them in cheap dog
biscuits while he rakes in the
government contracts but one thing we've
yet to touch on is just the basic
Logistics of this world I mean forget
dogs acting as police officers and
firefighters these dogs can talk like
talk like normal humans and while I've
largely ignored that fact till now since
animated Shogun to animate the new movie
threw that fact into Stark focus with
this one scene right here oh my goodness
I can talk I have so much to say dog are
really the only creatures that can talk
in this franchise every time a new pup
gets introduced bam they can speak
they're action figure ready and your kid
just found his new favorite character
you've got Everest way up in the
mountains tracker deep in the jungles
sweetie and Claw over in barkingburg
Liberty and the other dogs in the pound
of Adventure City rubble's family in
Builder Cove basically regardless of
what breed they are or where in the
world they are all dogs go to grammar
school but every other animal no we see
owls chickens fish cows goats Bears even
cats none of them are able to talk not a
single word crosses their lips beyond
what you'd expect a hoot a cluck a moo
here and there not even a syllable from
the kitten catastrophe crew the animal
Sidekicks of the show's main villain I
mean if any other animal were going to
talk in this franchise you'd think it'd
be them right and yet they're silent
until this new movie comes out and
suddenly they're given the power to
speak through a magic space Crystal so
what's going on here how do we explain
that well I can do it in a single word
for you aliens it's because the dogs in
Paw Patrol aren't dogs they're aliens
and yeah for all of you keeping track at
home this is the one one where I
officially lose my mind now for the sake
of completeness I should probably
mention a few exceptions to the only
dogs talk rule first there are the
merpups of puplantis puppy fish hybrids
who can't talk underwater but can after
they're magically altered into land pups
what's going on hey I can speak actual
topsider words I'm a land pup this makes
sense to me because the my pups
presumably evolved from Talking land
puppies and just lost the ability to
speak once underwater since you know
underwater speech ain't the most
effective way to communicate also can we
just acknowledge my personal brain rot
here I just said this makes sense to me
in regards to underwater mermaid dogs
talking that is a big self-revelation
moment secondly there's wild cat and the
CAT pack a group of feline friends
introduced in later Seasons to help
Ryder and the Gang and some of the
rescues and again this is called out as
weird to the show's characters because
cats in this world do not talk what you
can talk you can talk of course I can
talk and yet no one bats an eye to the
talking puppies why what exactly is
going on here well I think it all has to
start with that clip from the mighty
movie that I showed off earlier where we
watch as a member of the villain's
kitten catastrophe crew gains the
ability to speak through a space meteor
oh my goodness I can talk I have so much
to say the same meteor that gives the
PAW Patrol their superpowers as the
mighty pups also gives other normal
animals like cats the ability to talk
that right there seemed like an
important detail to me so like the good
boy that I am I started to do some
digging and it seemed like someone was
willing to throw me a bone see cats and
dogs are actually very well equipped for
full-on speech they have a lot of the
necessary organs required for the job
vocal cords Vocal Track even a voice box
this is how you see those cute videos of
dogs and cats sounding like they're
talking to their
owners but holding back man's best
friend and our feline familiars is
actually their brains they just lack a
more sophisticated brain that would
allow for speech for us humans the parts
of the brain that help us to talk would
be the broka area located in the left
hemisphere which enables speech and
articulation and War's area located in
the posterior Superior temporal lobe
which helps you comprehend the written
and spoken word so what does this space
Rock do into the cat that ALS also gives
it the ability to speak and how can it
also be given pups that are already able
to speak other superpowers like flight
and super speed one word radiation now
we've talked about this a lot before
specifically in our Magic School Bus
Theory but there's a lot of radiation
out in space enough so that it could be
deadly if you're not prepared for it
extended time spent in space and the
resulting exposure to radiation can
cause dramatic changes to an astronaut's
Behavior potentially even altering their
DNA with mutations and keep in mind that
meteors are just bathed in radiation all
day every day for potentially hundreds
of millions of years most of the time
this doesn't really result in any sort
of long-term changes to the space rocks
in fact most meteorites that fall to
Earth aren't anymore radioactive than
boring old Earth rocks but there are
plenty of exceptions in 2022 it was
reported that a special type of
radioactive meteorite known as a
carbonaceous condite might have been
what actually seated life onto Earth to
begin with it's feasible that what's
going on here is that this meteorite
that we see in the PAW Patrol is one of
these carbonaceous condr meteors falling
to Earth and mutating these dogs and
cats it's actually something even called
out in the movie movie there are normal
meteors but this one right here this is
one of the special ones it is actively
called out as one of the few meteors
floating around in space that has
special powers so there you have it
right we know that space radiation can
mutate people and alter their behavior
we know that meteors can be bathed in
space radiation and we know that in this
world radiated meteors are able to give
creatures the ability to talk so what's
that all have to do with the PAW Patrol
animals that were able to talk before
any meteors well I suspect that all the
dogs in the PAW Patrol verse aren't dogs
at all I think they're aliens now before
you say anything I get it that sounds
like a big old leap and normally I'd
agree but in this show aliens are well
established and frequently utilized part
of the lore a pair of aliens a mother
and her child are recurring characters
across the series and while these two
look like your typical aliens there's
also this completely separate species of
alien space rocks but even that's not
all the space alien has a dowel Based On
A Relic from the rhomboid Galaxy
implying that there's yet another
species floating around out there all in
all this proves that aliens come in many
different shapes and sizes here here so
puppy shaped aliens evolved by the
radiation of space to speak it's not out
of the question and what's more seems
like these aliens have a really Keen
interest in Adventure Bay and
specifically with the PAW Patrol they're
spotted multiple times throughout the
series sometimes just flying overhead on
the outskirts of town or studying the
local Wildlife outside of Adventure Bay
but also occasionally stopping by to
play a literal game of Frisbee with
Ryder and the boys it kind of makes you
wonder if the aliens are watching
Adventure Bas specifically we also see
them taking an active interest in dogs
with superpowers in the episode Pups
Save floating friends we see the aliens
pulling up a video of Apollo the super
dog a few years later in boom an alien
space meteor gives our faithful pups
their superpowers coincidence maybe all
in all I suspect that the dogs in the
PAW Patrol Universe started as a race of
aliens able to communicate due to the
mutations that space radiation had on
their system at some point
representatives of the species crashed
down on Earth and spread across the
planet diversifying and breaking out
into the different breeds that we see
today some went on to become merpups
losing the ability ility to speak
underwater While others tried mating
with native animals the cats yielding
the small minority of largely nonviable
genetic anomalies like the CAT pack but
at this point thousands even millions of
years later Humanity just accepts
talking dogs as a fact of life not worth
mentioning it's just part of how dogs as
created operate within this world except
someone here knows the truth someone
knows that dogs are more than meets the
eye and that someone is Ryder I suspect
that he knows all of this because let me
tell you Ryder's reaction to all this
alien stuff is incred incredibly strange
strange enough that I started getting
suspicious of our evil little capitalist
Mastermind see despite everything that
he's seen and done throughout his life
Ryder is still skeptical of a lot of
what the PAW Patrol encounters across
their Adventures for instance he really
doesn't believe in ghosts just straight
up dismissing them without a second
thoughts ghosts aren't real he's even
hesitant to believe any stories about
the myops despite having encountered
other mythical creatures before well
nobody's ever gotten a real good picture
of a mer pup it could have been
something else but do you know what
Ryder's reaction is to hearing that
aliens are around it's not Shock it's
not dismissal it's not even skepticism I
found a melon that was actually an alien
and he Za me with this cool bubble thing
and I Flo in the air like whoa whoa whoa
whoa where's the alien now yeah Ryder
immediately skips past the hole are you
sure it was an alien thing and just
jumps straight into well we're was it
there's no hesitation in his voice no
doubt it's almost like he already knew
that aliens were a thing and he was just
waiting for them to come around
Adventure Bay and this is important
because it's not like everyone else in
the series just knows that aliens are
real Mayor Goodway is shocked the first
time that aliens visit the town there
you
are oh dear this is not an everyday
occurrence and Ryder is not acting
normally here and then I noticed
something else all the technology that
Ryder makes and all that he has up in
the lookout sure does look a lot like
the technology that's present in the
alien spaceship enough so that the space
alien recognizes the lookout just at a
glance and heads inside when a spaceship
crash lands in Adventure Bay and I
totally get it when you put them side by
side the only difference between the
spaceship's interior and the lookout is
the color of the paneling enough so that
you kind of have to ask is this the same
technology even Ryder in the show says
this the lookout looks so much like a
spaceship he's trying to fly at home
there is definitely a connection here
and listen I know that this is just a
cartoon for children about talking dogs
reusing assets but there are just too
many coincidences in this world not only
does the alien recognize what to do with
the lookout but Ryder is able to use the
alien's Tech without any sort of trial
and error instantly figuring out how to
open the container holding the space
Rock alien additionally riter Tech it
doesn't just look like the alien Tech it
is instant compatible with it on more
than one occasion the space alien's
mother is able to hijack the lookout's
communication system with zero effort
and Rider is just able to tap into the
alien communication system by putting
his pup pad into super long distance
mode and it immediately picks up their
signal almost as if it were specifically
designed to be able to do that even
without technology when they weren't
able to make radio contact with the
aliens Ryder knows exactly how to get
their attention making a crop circle to
signal to them from space I mean the
only conclusion that we can take from
all this is that Ryder is somehow In
Cahoots with these aliens right or at
the very least that he's aware of them
and there's a good reason for that you
see not only are the PAW Patrol and all
these dogs aliens Ryder Ryder is an
alien too and not only are the PAW
Patrol and Rider aliens but every human
that you see in this series is also an
Alien aliens aliens everywhere aliens
seriously have you ever noticed that all
the humans in this world have only three
fingers and one thumb on their hands the
fact that this is so consistent tells me
that this isn't some weird regional
thing or a quirk of the people living in
Adventure Bay no this is a consistent
trait across their entire species and
that's when it clicked for me they're
all aliens and the thing that proves
that the humans in this world are also
aliens in the mighty pup special we see
a shot of the Paw Patrol planet from
orbits and well that ain't Earth friends
the continent structure that we see in
this one scream grab is unlike anything
that we have in our world or any
configuration of the continents that we
have ever thought to have existed this
right here is an alien planet not only
are the PAW Patrol Ancient Aliens every
single person you see in the series is
also an alien that's how you get talking
puppies and four fingered humans here
they're not humans that would also
explain the dinosaurs yeah the Dinosaurs
the dinosaurs that you can just drive on
over and visit there's also a Squatch in
this world Bigfoot where'd he come from
he must be an alien over in barkingburg
there's a literal Dragon a literal
Dragon aliens it's aliens all the way
down they say All Dogs Go to Heaven no
friends all dogs are aliens Blues Clues
alien Scooby-Doo alien all dogs descend
from the heavens who's a good theory
who's a good theory you are yeah a good
film Theory and
cuts you know the algorithms are
watching us right they're listening to
me they're pulling at my search data
right now and in case you didn't know we
actually have an official film Theory
Tik Tok page for all of these wild
ramblings lots of exclusive content over
there lots of it many theories like the
one at the top of this episode casual
theories that are a little bit more
unhinged fun facts about the world of
movies and film that you are almost
certainly not aware of it is going to be
an awesome and pretty wacky time so you
should absolutely come on over and join
us over there that's at film theorist
official over on Tik Tok alternatively
if you're more of a still image sort of
guy we also have an official theorist
Instagram page at Team theorist that'll
have exclusive behind the-scenes content
from the entire theorist Cinematic
Universe we'd love to have you join us
join us join us join us